[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après leur très bon début en championnat
de France de football les Toulousains
maillot foncés ont connu sur leur
terrain face au bord deeled et lendemain
qui déchante il est vrai qu'on a très
peu joué au football sur la pelouse
ensoleillée du Stadium municipal
transformé pour les 3/ de la partie en
ring de
combat pas une attaque qui ne se soit
terminé comme cela et il ne s'agit là
que d'un petit
he cette mê confuse devant les BU
bordelais se termine par un drame le
Toulousain ma est touché à la
tête résultat commotion cérébrale ça
c'est du SP ça ne suffit pas à calmer
les esprits l'arbitre est complètement
débordé malgré son air placide les
agressions reprennent de plus Bell tant
d'un côté que de l'autre ce n'est plus
un match c'est une bataille de rue et il
n'y a pas de raison pour que ça s'arrête
et dire que 20000 spectateurs ont payé
pour voir cela et pour ne rien arranger
un incident d'arbitrage remet le feu au
poudre les Bordelais certes n'ont pas
joué très élégamment mais ils ne sont
tout de même pas responsables si
l'arbitre leur a accordé un but sur coup
franc parfaitement justifi ils étaient
là tout de même pour essayer de gagner
leur match et malgré la colère des
Toulousains le résultat est sans appel 1
à0 pour Bordeaux mais de toute façon
zéro de conduite pour les deux
[Applaudissements]
équipes nouveau pas en avant dans les
relations franco-allemandes monsieur
George Pompidou a présidé avec Monsieur
EEC ministre allemand de la famille et
de la jeunesse à l'installation de
l'Office franco-allemand pour la
jeunesse dont le but est d'organiser des
échanges de jeunes entre les deux pays
le général de Gaulle en recevant à
l'Élysée les membres du nouvel office a
salué cette création qui intéresse
quelques 25 millions de jeunes Français
et Allemands et dont l'action commencera
dès cet
Ivet le lac toplitz dans les Alpes
autrichiennes va-t-il enfin livrer son
secret le gouvernement autrichien vient
en effet d'y envoyer une équipe de
chercheurs muni d'un matériel technique
considérable et de déclarer zone
interdite les abords du lac une légende
Tenas désigne en effet le lact tooplitz
comme l'endroit où auraiit été immergés
les fabuleux trésors nazi et certains
décès suspects survenus à cet endroit
n'ont fait qu'ajouter aux
hypothèses le célèbre spectacle d'olid
on Ice avec ses danseuses évoluant sur
la patinoire s'est terminé cette fois en
tragédie au colisé d'Indianapolis aux
États-Unis où le spectacle s'achevait un
quart d'heure plus tard qu'à l'ordinaire
un quart d'heure fatal une énorme
explosion venue du sous-sol et branla
l'immense vaisseau pendant que les loges
et les balcons littéralement soufflaient
étit projeté avec leurs occupants
jusqu'au sein des blocs de ciment
arrachés par l'explosion retombaient
dans la foule pendant qu'une flamme
gigantesque jaillissait du sous-sol
pendant que les danseuses quittaient les
coulisses dans leur costumes de scène un
spectacle tragique s'étalait dans
l'arène des décombres on dégageait des
blessés et des
morts des 6000 spectateurs qui
applaudissaient tout à l'heure
385 portaient des blessures plus ou
moins graves et le bilan funèbre était
lourd c'est 62 cadavres en effet que les
équipes de secours alignaient sur la
[Musique]
piste la conférence de bamaco a réussi
du moins a-telle abouti à une signature
le roi Hassan 2 et le président Ben B
accueill tour à tour par le président du
Mali modibita et le ngus devaent
parvenir grâce à l'intervention de ces
derniers à un accord de cess le feu
après de jours de négociation au cours
desquel les deux adversaires refusèrent
d'abord de se rencontrer l'action des
deux médiateurs fit prévaloir une
formule qui pouvait obtenir
l'assentiment du Maroc et de l'Algérie
c'est donc cette formule que signè Ben
Bella d'un air grave le roi Hassan d'un
air
souriant et lare poigné de main
[Applaudissements]
entretemps les forces marocaines avaient
repris au nord de Tindouf le poste
d'ouelchar occupé par une unité
algérienne les adversaires laissèrent
sur le terrain des morts et des blessés
et 40 algériens furent faits prisonniers
avec leurs
[Musique]
armes d'autres actions du même genre
devaient se produire bien après l'heure
fixée pour le cesselffeu et le nom de
figig situé en terre marocaine emporté
par les Algériens puis reprise par les
Marocains a fait peser pendant 3 jours
une nouvelle interrogation sur la fin
des
[Musique]
combats pour la 7e fois le 27 octobre au
cœur de saon un bon s'était donné la
mort par le feu en signe de protestation
contre le régime du président de Godin
diem
cette image effroyable devenait la
préface du coup d'État qui devait
emporter le
régime quelques jours plus tard en effet
le gouvernement de di sombit sous les
coups de l'armée révolté di lui-même et
son frère l'homme fort du régime trouv
la mort dans les acôtés sanglants de ce
coup
d'État voici les prières images tourné
après la rédition de la garde spéciés
président qui résista une journée aux
forces des 16 généraux qui conduisirent
le mouvement et qui se sont emparés du
pouvoir la lutte a été dure en certains
endroit et certains immeubles défendus
avec acharnement ont été attaqués au
canon et au
[Musique]
mortiers devant le palais présidentiel
longuement défendu et saccagé après les
combats une foule considérable a
manifesté son contentement devant les
gardes prisonniers et les vainqueurs
satisfait un nouveau régime prend donc
la place de Diem dont le buste blessé
contemple la ruine de son pouvoir
nouveau régime qui sa dès la première
heure donné pour programme l'Union
national et la lutte contre le
[Musique]
communisme le chakra
rajou ce pic de plus de 6000 m dans la
Cordière des Indes restait inviolet ses
pentes abruptes presque verticales la
glace et la neige qui le recouvrent par
endroit en toute saison semblaient
s'opposer à tout escalade c'est pourtant
son ascension tenté et réussi par une
équipe que conduisait Claude Maillard
Lionel Teré et Guido Magon que nous
restitu les images de Jean-Jacques
langpin qui faisait partie de
l'expédition la dernière étape fut la
plus dure c'est celle dont vous suivez
les difficiles progrès l'apreté du décor
la difficulté de l'entreprise le danger
toujours présent et le courage des
hommes se passe de
[Musique]
parole une neige instable des corniches
sans cesse prêtes à s'écrouler des
parois de roches lisses qui ne donnent
aucune prise des apies à 80°r les
alpinistes ont tout connu au cours de
cette ascension où le moindre faux pas
signifiait la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mort
[Musique]
et pourtant dans un dernier assaut qui
Dua à 3 jours l'étonnante prouesse
sportive est réalisée à plus de 6000 m
dominant une mer de pics enneigé
l'équipe française fait flotter son
drapeau au grand vent des
Simes chakra Raju un nom de plus au
palmarès de l'alpinisme
[Musique]
français